hello and welcome back now we're going
to speak to an author about his new
novel right now which talks about
resetting categorization and his allergy
to conflict between cultures most
inhabited the author the light
last white man a novel about white
americans who wake up dark skinned and
i'm pleased to say as i said he joins us
now
good to have you with us um i mean it's
a it's an interesting concept just tell
us a little bit about it
so the novel begins with a young man
named anders in an unnamed country who
wakes up dark
and when he went to bed uh the evening
before he wasn't and this predicament
starts to spread
and it's so it's it's sci-fi it's
basically that goes around and people do
they go from white to black do they go
the other way around as well well we
don't know um and i think you know
partly what the novel does is it makes
the reader imagine things and it gives
some hints as to how you can imagine but
what you wind up imagining comes at
least partly from you and so the novel i
guess is inviting readers to make stuff
up and then see how that makes them feel
and it's about how we are i guess
present ourselves in the world and how
the world sort of puts things upon us
yeah it i think it begins from the idea
that um that like race is an imaginary
thing we kind of made it up um it
doesn't actually exist it's not like a
waterfall there's questions that were
put in place yeah you know this stuff
this stuff has been invented upon us and
so
what happens if we stop being able to
see it what happens if we can't tell
what race people are what do we do
that's what the novel explores give us
some of the inspiration because when i
when i saw the novel and i read through
the praise of it i was reminded of a
work of non-fiction franz fanon's black
skin white mask which is this idea of
categorization and who we are and how
the world seizes was that an inspiration
for this well i mean fanon is obviously
somebody that i read and and uh had a
big impact when i was a young man um in
a way one of the inspirations was what
happened to me you know after 9 11 as a
30 year old brown skinned you know
muslim named man living in a city like
new york and uh university educated with
a good income i didn't encounter that
much discrimination i suppose before
there was some
but it went to an entirely different
level almost overnight and i hadn't
changed but in a sense the way i was
being imagined by other people had
changed and that idea sort of lodged in
me that that you know it's possible to
sort of radically reimagine one's race
um or have it reimagined upon you so
what if it went the opposite direction
you know what if somebody like anders
woke up and had this happen to him and
how does without spoilers how does
anders handle that well andrew's first
doesn't want to believe it's happening
he wants to think that it hasn't
happened or that it won't make a big
deal or that he's the same person but
what he begins to discover is that even
though he is the same person he isn't
because um the way you're seen by others
does start shaping how you act and he
begins to act quite differently i mean
are we trying to get in this novel to
the point where race doesn't matter
anymore or you telling us something else
that it massively does matter and still
and still will do going forward well a
bit of both i mean i think um i think
race is something that we need to
imagine our way out of
i think it's an incredibly pernicious
idea that flattens people and puts them
in categories that are sort of made up
that said it's real
because we believe in it it does things
in our world
so what the novel does is it allows the
reader to go into a slightly
uncomfortable place where they have to
imagine what's going on they have to see
how that makes them feel they have to
sit with it and and then they have to
deal with their responses it's it's i
guess an invitation to go into your own
imagination and see how things shape you
i mean what are your reflections on the
way that society is right now you talked
about the way that you felt you were
treated post-9 11. what about right now
in 2022 how does it feel being in the
world as you well i think that for a
long time i imagined that things were
going to get better that in fact we
lived in a world where racism would
reduce for inequality would reduce where
the environment would get better et
cetera um i'm 51 and so for the first
you know 30 35 40 years maybe it was
possible to believe that but
increasingly it's become hard to have
that kind of optimism it seems that in
fact maybe we were at sort of peak good
environment or peak progressive ethos
some time ago when around 2008 2008.
barack obama the arc of history bends to
the good that was his face i think i
think that's right i think when obama
was elected there was a feeling that
things were going in a particular
direction
um and subsequent uh events have
suggested that that's not the case the
rise of strong men leaders all over the
place the continued environmental
degradation and and the rise of you know
overtly racist discourse in many places
and so i think that it's it's very
dangerous to be pessimistic about this
stuff i think we have to kind of find
our way to an optimistic viewpoint um
and and that's going to be a kind of
critical optimism so that's what we're
trying to do okay so expand on that we
don't have much time but how do you get
to that optimistic point because what
you're saying is like you've taken the
words right out of my head so a very
brief thing if you aren't optimistic you
wind up being nostalgic if you're
nostalgic your politics becomes let's go
back to how things were how things were
was rarely very good
to escape that you have to say you know
how might things be how might we want
them to be you know how do we get there
and the novel tries to do a little bit
of that it tries to say you know what
other way is there of living
how might that be what is the in a sense
racial apocalypse where everybody
becomes brown um and maybe
that racial apocalypse isn't an
apocalypse at all maybe it's the
beginning of something you know better
some opening and awakening wait time but
i could talk to you all morning but we
don't have the time love to speak to you
the book is out now it's called the last
point man it's available in all good
books awesome online i'm sure love to
speak to you thanks for being thank you